Hello Margate residents my name is
Graham Razey and i'm the chair of the
Margate Town Deal board.
We have been presented with a fantastic
opportunity by government as part of 101
towns and cities from across England
chance to bid for up to 25 million
pounds worth of funding
to support the regeneration and economic
recovery of Margate and its surrounding
area.
This is where we need you. The chance to get
involved and shape that future.
You could do that by either engaging
with us in physical meetings,
in digital coffee mornings, there's a
chance to take part in a survey
there's also a chance to apply to become
part of our people's board.
To find out more information please
visit margatetowndeal.co.uk
I really look forward to working with
you all over the coming weeks months and
years
and you know making Margate the best
place that we can possibly make it to be
you